can you describe
some of the key ideas in the history of
physics maybe lingering on each
from electromagnetism to relativity to
quantum mechanics and to today as we'll
talk about with quantum gravity and
strength theory sure so um i mentioned
the classical mechanics and the euler
lagrange formulation
one of the next important milestones for
physics were
the discoveries of laws of their
christian magnetism
so maxwell put put the discoveries all
together in the context of what we call
the maxwell's equations
and he noticed that when he put these
discoveries that
you know faradays and others had made
about electric and magnetic phenomena
the
in terms of mathematical equations it
didn't quite work
there was a mathematical inconsistency
now
uh you know one could have had two
attitudes one say okay who cares about
math i'm doing nature you know electric
force magnetic force
math i don't care about but it bothered
him it was inconsistent the equations
you were writing the two equations he
had written down did not agree with each
other
and this bothered him but he figured out
you know if you add this jiggle this
equation by adding one little term there
it works
at least it's consistent what is the
motivation for that term
he said i don't know have we seen it in
experiments no
why did you add it well because of
mathematical consistency so he said
okay math forced him to
do this term he added this term which we
now today call the maxwell term
and once he added that term his
equations were nice you know
differential equations mathematically
consistent beautiful
but you also found the new physical
phenomena he found that
because of that term he could now get
electric and magnetic
waves moving through space
at a speed that he could calculate so he
calculated the speed of the wave
and lo and behold he found it's the same
as the speed of light
which puzzled him because he didn't
think light had anything to do with
electricity and magnetism
but then he was courageous enough to say
well maybe light is nothing but these
electric and magnetic fields moving
around
and he didn't he wasn't alive to see the
verification of that prediction and
indeed was true so this mathematical
inconsistency which which we could say
you know this mathematical beauty drove
him
to this physical very important
connection
between light and electromagnetic
phenomena which was
later confirmed so then physics
progresses and it comes to einstein
einstein looks at maxwell's equation
this is beautiful these are a nice
equation except
we get one speed light who measures this
light speed and he asks the question are
you
are you moving are you not moving if you
move the speed of light changes but
maxwell's equation has no hint of
different speeds of light it doesn't say
oh
only if you're not moving you get the
speed it's just you always get the speed
so
einstein was very puzzled and he he was
daring enough to say well you know maybe
everybody get the same speed for light
yeah and that motivated this theory of
special relativity
and this is an interesting example
because the idea was motivated from
physics from
maxwell's equations from the fact that
people try to
try to measure the properties of ether
which was supposed to be the medium in
which the light travels through
and the idea was that only in that in
that medium the speed the speed of
if you're at rest with respect to the
ether the speed the speed of light then
if you are moving the speed changes
and people did not discover it michaels
and morley's experiments show there is
no ether
so then einstein was courageous enough
to say you know light is
the same speed for everybody regardless
of whether you're moving or not
and the interesting thing is about
special theory of relativity is that
the under the math underpinning it is
very simple
it's linear algebra nothing terribly
deep
you can teach it at a high school level
if not earlier
okay is does that mean einstein's
special relativity is boring
not at all so this is an example where
simple math you know
linear algebra leads to deep physics
einstein's theory of special relativity
motivated by this inconsistency at max
world
equation would suggest for the speed of
light depending on who observes it
what's the most daring idea there that
that the the speed of light could be the
same everywhere that's the basic that's
the guts of it that's the core of
einstein's theory that statement
underlies the whole thing speed of light
is the same for everybody it's hard to
swallow
and it doesn't sound right it sounds
completely wrong on the face of it
and it was it took einstein to make to
make this the daring statement
it would be it'd be laughing in some
sense how could possibly how could
anybody make
this possibly ridiculous claim and it
turned out to be true how does that make
you feel
because it it still sounds ridiculous it
sounds ridiculous until you learn that
our intuition is at fault about the way
we conceive of space and time
the way we think about space on time is
wrong because we think about the nature
of time as absolute
and part of it is because we live in a
situation where we don't go with very
high speeds that our speeds are small
compared to the speed of light
and therefore the phenomena we we
observe does not distinguish the
relativity of time
the time also depends on who measures it
there's no absolute time
when you say it's noon today now it
depends on who's measuring it and
it not everybody would agree with that
statement and to see that
you will have to have fast observer
moving you know speeds close to speed of
light so
so this shows that our intuition is at
fault and
a lot of the discoveries in physics
precisely
is getting rid of the wrong old
intuition
and it is funny because we get rid of it
but it always lingers
in us in some form like even when i'm
describing it i feel like a little bit
like isn't it you know funny
as you're just feeling the same way it
is yes it is but we kind of
replace it by an intuition
you